a wizard arrives precisely when he means
to unless the show runners have other
ideas is it even possible for gandalf to
appear in the rings of power with visits
to locations like khazar doom and
appearances from elrond and galadriel
the lord of the rings the rings of power
is already teasing the future adventures
led by heroic hobbits however there's
one part of this sprawling fantasy that
will no doubt have viewers scratching
their heads specifically some might be
wondering if one particular character is
set to become the legendary wizard and
guardian of middle earth gandalf we are
of course referring to the stranger who
flew in at the end of the show's first
episode and landed in the path of
adventurous half foot nori brandyfoot
while the character is yet to reveal
their name this first look hints at all
the essential physical attributes of
everyone's favorite wizard tower ring
over the brave little halfling who is an
ancestor of hobbits his tall frame works
perfectly under the long grey cloak he's
been given the character also appears to
have the essential facial feature that
makes gandalf who he is a great big
bushy beard beyond the physical details
a few more character traits are on
display hinting that this might be the
wizard we know and love of course
gandalf is more than just a wizard as
he's also an ancient and ethereal being
gandalf the grey began as a maya part of
an angelic order of creatures that made
up one half of the einer some of the
einer including gandalf was sent to help
elves and men battle against sauron in
the third age this group was called
istari which is elvish for the term
wizard this duty came with a catch
though as these supernatural saviors
would be sent in human form so as to not
scare the locals as tolkien revealed in
unfinished tales but this would imperil
them dimming their wisdom and knowledge
and confusing them with fears cares and
wariness coming from the flesh the
stranger's mysterious entrance certainly
suggests he embodies some of these
attributes but it's the skills he
displays that hint he might be gandalf
specifically for instance when nori
tries to communicate with this man from
beyond the stars the sky turns black and
the trees buckle under his booming voice
his bellows echo a similar note to
gandalf when he terrifies bilbo in the
fellowship of the ring
do not take me for some conjurer of
cheap tricks
we also see the stranger whispering to
the fireflies to help show the
constellation of stars he's been
scribbling into the ground it's the same
method gandalf uses when he asks a moth
to go and get the eagles to aid him in
breaking free of saramon's grasp both
instances hinted gandalf's particular
set of skills that said it's also
possible that this assumption is a total
setup given the time in which we've
returned to middle earth before the one
ring ruined everything as much as amazon
is taking creative liberties with
tolkien's massive world for the rings of
power one significant alteration could
also see them playing around with the
timeline of middle earth when it comes
to gandalf's activities and arrival he
doesn't roll into town until the third
age which begins after sauron's demise
at the hand of isildor so this potential
mr grey is appearing far too early by
tolkien's count then again given that
during the fourth could be digging
himself a dangerous hole in khazar doom
which could lead to the balrog the show
might be tampering with tolkien's
history on a grander scale than
anticipated there's every chance that
the minds behind the rings of power
might be intentionally toying with our
knowledge of this fantastic world if
that's the case then they could
eventually reveal the stranger to be a
different wizard altogether perhaps one
of the five history that ultimately
becomes corrupted by sauron's power in
the centuries to come let's not forget
that anything gandalf can do saruman can
do just as well and was originally on
the side of good before being caught in
the gaze of sauron's evil eye could this
man of mystery be a wizard that
eventually goes bad we can only wait and
see as the rings of power continues
[Music]